في اول رد فعل له بعض المؤتمر الصحفي
للهيئه العليا للانتخابات اكد الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان كوادر والي
جانا حزبه سيواصلون العمل بلا توقف لضمان
الفوز في جوله الاعاده من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والمزمع عقدها في 28 من الشهر
الجاري جاء ذلك في تغريد نشرها الرئيس
التركي عقب اجتماعه باعضاء اللجنه
المركزيه لحزب العداله والتنميه في
العاصمه التركيه انقره وشكر اردوغان الشعب
التركي او المشاركين في الانتخابات الذين
بلغ عددهم سته وخمسين مليونا على ما سماه
المشاركه الفاعله والقويه في الانتخابات
مؤكدا ان هذه المشاركه الكبيره دليل على
نضج ومتانه التجربه الديمقراطيه في بلاده
حسب وصفه ووعد الرئيس التركي جمهوره
الانتخابي بانهم سيخرجون منتصرين ليله
الثامن والعشرين من مايو الجاري في اشاره
لتاريخ جوله الاعاده